les pires tragédies de l'histoire de
l'humanité ont eu lieu quand nous nous
sommes trouvés devant des choses
inconnues
effrayante
toute l'attention des agences de presse
internationales est focalisée sur moscou
voudrait pas de presser mais il faudra
attendre environ 50 ans pour la
prochaine pluie de météorites
où l'on gect entrée dans l'atmosphère je
ne suis pas si nos caméras
ça fait des siècles des milliers
d'années que nous attendons d'entrer en
contact avec des extraterrestre il y à
une rallonge à qui n'a pas été notifiée
s'est écrasé au milieu des immeubles de
chartes à nouveau
ces bannières ça dépend de ce qu'ils
vont faire maintenant
une arme ils sont venus pourquoi d'après
toi je sais pas encore
nous ne savons pas ce qu'ils font c'est
pourquoi vous devez leur expliquer il
s'agit là d'une chance extraordinaire
pour toute l'humanité
une chance d'essayer de comprendre
savoir qui nous sommes
faire un autre rapport ils ont dit de ne
pas approcher on pourrait ainsi éviter
d'avoir d'autres types cette destruction
je vous rappelle que nous on n'a encore
jamais attaqué personne
ce nom protège
alors tu viens d'une autre galaxie on
vit avec châtellerault